[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات
وفي العناوين
الانفجار كان بالتزامن مع التحليق طائره
مسيره عند ضفاف المرصد يقول انفجار استهدف
مبنى للمليشيات الايرانيه في دير الزور
وخلف قتلى وجرحه
على البوابه الشرقيه لباخمت يحذر من
تداعيات سقوطها
ايران تعلن ايقاف عدد من المشتبه بهم في
عمليه تصميم طالبات المدارس وتصيفهم
بالمشاغبين
ما في مشكله بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
مشكله بين الناس المكرسين في السلطه
في هجوم اللاذع قائد قوات الدعم السريعه
السودانيه ينتقد العسكريين المتمسكين
بالسلطه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا قال المرفض السوري
لحقوق الانسان ان الانفجار الذي وقع في
دير الزور اليوم استهدف مبنى للفسايا
الايرانيه ما اسفر عن مقتل اربعه اشخاص
واضاف من مدير المرصد العربي على
الاستهداف تزامن مع تحليق طائرات مسيره
بالمنطقه وتسبب ايضا في اصابه ثمانيه
عناصر من هذه الفصائل وكان اعلام نظام
السوري افاد في وقت سابق بمقتل ثلاثه
تنظيم داعش في حي الحميديه بدير الزور
مشاهدينا معنا
وما هي المعطيات او ماذا تقول المعطيات
المتوفيه لكم حول هذا الهجوم خاصه مع
تضارب حول كوني هجوم بطائره مسيره او بلغم
ارضي كما يقول النظام السوري
نعم صباح الخير طبعا مجددا دعنا نقول بان
موضوع اللغم الارضي امر يعني محسوم بشكل
كامل لا يوجد شيء اسمه لغه ارضيه يتسبب
بهذا الدمار هائل في تلك المنطقه هذا
الامر محسوم ومنتهي بالنسبه لنا ومؤكد
بانه لا يوجد لهم ارضي دمرت تلك المنطقه
وسبب بهذا المنشار الكبير بالنسبه
لاستهداف الطائره المسيره لمخزن الاسلحه
هل هو استهداف من قبل هذه الطائره المسيره
التي ادت لهذا الانفجار ام هو انفجار من
على الارض في عمليه امنيه استهدفت هذه
الميليشيات ولكن ما جرى من هذا الانفجار
فضح موضوع تخزين السلاح تخزين مصانع
الاسلحه ضمن مناطق مدنيه وهنا نقول للنظام
حقيقه الامر الولد الذي
في تلك بان هذا مربع هو مربع ايراني ويعلم
بان هذه المشافي والمستوصفات والمنازل
يقوم فيها ما يعرف بحجاج حزب الله او حجاج
ايرانيين
الانفجار استهدفا مستودع للايرانيين مصنع
لتصنيع صواريخ ما تعرف بصواريخ قصيره
المدى التابعه الايرانيين في هذه البقعه
المدنيه من التراب السوري وهل الوصول
بانها منطقه مدنيه صرفه والانفجار تسببها
في دمار هائل هل الطائر المسيره التي كانت
تحلق عند ضفاف الفرات هي التي استهدفت هذا
المبنى الى الان لم يستطيع التاكيد او
النفي ولكن الامر مرتبط ببعضه هل هناك
كانت تراقب عمليه ان الامر سيتم والانفجار
سيتم في تلك المنطقه الانفجار مثل ما
شاهدنا سواء انفجار شديد هو بشكل قطعي ليس
انفجار نغب بشكل اذا لم يكن هذا الانفجار
ناجم عنهم كما يقول النظام ما الذي يدفع
النظام السوري لتبني هذه الروايه في
تقديرك يا اخي يا سيد نظام اخر من يعلم في
تلك المناطق يدور يعني حقيقه امر النظام
لا يعلم بان هنا قد يكون النظام ذات لا
يعلم بان هناك قيادي من حزب الله يختم في
هذه الفيلا او تلك في الاراضي السوريه
يعلم بان تلك المنطقه للاصدقاء الاصدقاء
يعني حلفاء النظام السوري ولكن لا يعلم
يمنع عليه ان يعلم ماذا يدور في تلك
المنطقه لان الايرانيين وحزب الله في كثير
من الحالات لا يفيقون بالنظام السوري
والذين يتعاملون مع النظام السوري ويخشونه
ان يكونوا عملاء لاسرائيل او روايات
المتحده الامريكيه اذا كان النظام ايضا
يستغلون هذه المناطق المدنيه لتخزين
الاسلحه كما تفضلت هل يشمل ذلك ايضا
المستشفى الايراني هل كان هدفا لهذا
الانفجار او هذا الهجوم يعني هو المشفى
الايراني وقع في منطقه المشفى الايراني
يعني في البدايه عندما نشرنا الخبر قلنا
منطقه المشفى الايراني يعني بال
اراضي في كف
ن المدرسه الايرانيه اين المدارس السوريه
واين المشافي السوريه واين ابناء الشعب
السوري ولماذا ايران تصر ان تبقى في داخل
التراب السوري وان سوريا يجب ان تستمر
بالتدمير على التمدد ايراني على حساب
ابناء الشعب السوري الى متى لا نعلم طيب
اخر التحديثات حول الاحصائيات حول اعداد
القتلى والمصابين ايضا بحسب ما توفر لكم
بمعلومات سيد رامي المؤكد هم اربعه الى
الان ثمانيه جرحى لكن هذا الرقم المؤكد
وهناك معلومات بان هناك المزيد من الخسائر
البشريه لكن حتى اللحظه ما نستطيع تاكيده
بان هناك اربعه قتلوا وثم شكرا
لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن
مشاهدينا مع تزايد الصراع العنيف الذي
يدور في الوقت الراهن حول مدينه
بين القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه نقل
المكتب الاعلامي لمؤسس شركه فاغن العسكريه
روسيه قوله ان قواته بل ان قواته سيطرت
بشكل كامل على القسم الشرقي لمدينه مؤكدا
ان كل ما يقع شرق نهر المدينه بات الان
تحت سيطره قوه
ان السيطره على مدينه بخ موت مساله اساسيه
لشن مزيد من الهجمات في دونيسكي وقال
شويغو خلال اجتماع مع مسؤولين عسكريين ان
مدينه بخم تشكل مركزا دفاعيا مهما للقوات
الاوكرانيه في منطقه مشيرا الى ان السيطره
عليها ستسمح بهجمات اضافيه في عمق خطوط
دفاع القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه هذا هو
اعلنت هيئه الاركان في الجيش الاوكراني
التصدي لاكثر من 100 هجوم روسي في باخمت
وبقيه محافظ تونيسكا
واشارت في بيان الى ان الهجمات الروسيه
تضمنت 24 غاره جويه و60 قصفا صاروخيا من
منصات اطلاق صواريخ متعدده وطائرات مسيره
ايرانيه الصنع واضافت هيئه اركان اوكرانيه
ان الطيران الاوكرانيه استهدف خمسه تجمعات
للقوات الروسيه وثلاثه مستودعات للوقود
بسبع غارات جويه هذا وقال الرئيس
الاوكرانية من باكموت سيفتح الطريقه امام
القوات الروسيه لاحتلال المدن الاخرى
واضاف رئيس الاوكراني ان روسيا تريد
السيطره على
ان روسيا تحتاج لانتصار لتعيد تعبئه تعبئه
المشاعر لدى شعبها على حد قوله
مشاهدينا مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد
اهلا بك عبد الجواد يعني المتابع لتصريحات
وزير الدفاع الروسيه راى ان هناك توافقا
في الداخل الروسي حول مدى اهميه بحموت لكن
السؤال المطروحون عبر الجواب حول اسباب
هذه الخلافات بين قيادات الدفاع الروسيه
ايضا
مرحبا احمد نعم في الحقيقه يعني المجتمع
الروسي من الداخل ينظر الى قضيه فخمت على
انها اليوم هي المعركه الكبرى الثانيه بعد
معركه ماريوبل قبل نحو عام من الان لكن
بما يخص قضيه الخلافات التي تظهر على
النعم بالفعل يعني مؤسس مجموعه فاقنر يعود
ويطلق ويوجه النار من جديد نحو وزاره
الدفاع حول النقص بالامدادات العسكريه
والذخيره لمقاتله لكن طبعا حتى هذه اللحظه
احمد ما زالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تتحدث
عن ان مجموعه فاجنر هي مجموعه عسكريه
قتاليه تضم في صفوفها المرتزقه وعليها
طبعا العمل بشكل كبير على تامين كافه
مستلزماتها لكن بعض الاراء السياسيه في
البلاد احمد تحدثت بواقعيه حول هذا
الموضوع بان عمل فاغنر اليوم في باخموت
وامدادها بالسلاح وبالصوا الدعم يعني
الجوي من الطيران والمروحيات والقذائف
والصواريخ التي تطلق من البحر الاسود هذا
الشيء يضع طبعا في الواجهه تحت مظله وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه لذلك طبعا لا يمكن تحقيق
هذا النوع من السيطره على الارض دون
الاعتماد على وزاره الدفاع الروسي طيب
ابدو جواد يعني
الدفاع الروسيه هناك من يتساء ايضا عن دور
الرئيس بوتين من هذا التجاذبات هل يلعب
دورا في تقريب وجهه النظر طيب يعد جواد
اعتذر منك نحن مضطره للانتقاء الى
الاستوكهولم لمتابعه هذه الكلمه
للمسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في احد اوروبا
الاجراءات لتجاوز بعض التحديات ودعونا لا
ننسى
موضوع الايبولا لكن اوكرانيا هي في قمه
الاولويات كما ان يوم غد
سيكون او اليوم هو يوم المراه وبهذا هذه
المناسبه
لدينا
[موسيقى]
هذا هو
برنامج عملنا اليوم
باستثناء
انه سيكون مجلس مهم جدا وسنرى كيف سيكون
رد الوزراء على مقترحي
لا ياتي من السماء
وهذا يعني انه ليس
بان دوله تقول انها علينا ان نحصل على
مزيد من التمويل وهذا يعني ان المال ليس
بمتوفر بل علينا ان نرى ان كانت الدول
الاعضاء
ستقدم المزيد سيشدنا ذلك لكن اليوم ساطلب
منهم فقط ان يساهموا بقدر ما يستطيعون
دعونا نكون براجماتيين ولا نناقش
النهايه ولكن الواقع وما يحدث على الارض
الان
وان نحترم
الحقائق
المجتمع الاوروبي مستعد لح
الموارد ونحن
مستعدين للتمويل
بمئه مليون ولا اريد ان اتحدث عن رقم كبير
بل هو سيكون رقم مهم جدا
الاربعين بالمئه ستكون من الدول
الاعضاء
والبقيه هي
منحسبنا الارقام فهي ليست بعيده عن الهدف
نكس فيها حياديه في دستورها
نحن نعلم والجميع يعلم ان المال
متوفر لكن حياديه هم نحترمها بشكل كبير
بهذا القدر وفي متابعه لسياق نشاطنا وفي
كلمه امام البرلمان الكندي قالت رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبي ارسل ان الاتحاد
الاوروبيه لن يقبل ابدا بان تهدد روسيا
امنه واضافته ان الاتحاد لن يقبل بان ترسل
قوه عسكريه لديها احلام امبراطوريه
دباباتها الى ما وراء الحدود الدوليه هذا
واكدت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ان دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي لن تقبل بهذا التهديد
لامن اوروبا ولاسس المجتمع الدولي مشدده
على وجوب ان تدفع روسيا ثمن جريمه عدوانها
على اوكرانيا
قال المتحدث باسم الكريم
حشو اعلامي منسق معتبرا ان مدبريل عمل
ارهابي يريدون تشتيت الانتباه واكد ان
التقارير ليست غربيه فحسب بل تفوح منها
رائحه الجريمه الوحشيه على حد وصفه مشيرا
الى ان الكريم لا يفهم كيف يعتبر
المسؤولون الامريكيون حادثه خطي انابيب
التيار الشمالي عمل الارهابيا دون اجراء
تحقيق واضاف بسقف ان روسيا لا تزال غير
قادره على الوصول لوثائق تحقيقات
السويد مؤكدا ان على الدول المستثمره في
نورد ستريم وكذلك الامم المتحده ان تطلب
تحقيقا سريعا وشفافا في التفجير
من جانبها قالت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان لا
علاقه لكيف بتفكير خط نورد ستريم بدورها
اكدت الحكومه الالمانيه ان تحقيق المشتركه
مع الدنمارك والسويد بشان توفير مستمر ولم
يصل لنتيجه بعد وكذلك بل ذلك بعد ان تحدث
الصحيفه عن تقييم الاستخبارات الامريكيه
اشار الى ان مجموعه اوكرانيا نفذت الهجوم
على خطوط العام الماضي كما اشارت تقريره
الى انه لم يثبت بعد ما اذا كان رئيس
الاوكراني على علم بالهجوم الذي قد يكون
نفد من مجموعه اوكرانيه
ياتي هذا مشاهدينا فيما شكك وزير الدفاع
الالماني بولس في المعلومات الاستخبارتي
التي اكدت ان جماعه المواليه لاوكرانيا
كانت وراء الهجمات على خطوط وقال ان هذه
العمليه ربما تكون مرفقه من روسيا لالقاء
اللوم على اوكرانيا وايجاد مبرر للحرب
وجارى الى ان هناك احتمالات اخرى لا تقل
ترجيحا عن اتهام اوكرانيا بالوقوف وراء
هجمه
من يقف وراء تفجير خطي انابيب نور ستريم
صحيفه ديتسايت الالمانيه كشفت ان محققين
دوليين عثروا على القارب الذي استخدم
لتفخيخ انابيب نوت ستريم وان منفذي
العمليه فريق كوماندوس اوكراني
الحكومه الالمانيه اكدت ان التحقيق
المشترك مع الدنمارك والسويد بشان تفجير
نورت ستريم مستمر ولم يصل لنتيجه بعد
صحيفه دنيور تايمز كشفت عن تقييم
للاستخبارات الامريكيه اشار الى ان مجموعه
اوكرانيه نفذت الهجوم على خطوط نورت ستريم
العام الماضي
التقرير الذي يتحدث عن تورط اوكرانيا
بالتفجير نورتريم يبرر طلب موسكو واجراء
تحقيق مستقل بهذا الشان هذا ما قاله مندوب
روسيا الدائم لدى الامم المتحده فاسدين
من جانبها اعلنت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان
كياث غير متورطه على الاطلاق في الاعتداء
على خطي انابيب ولا معلومات لديها عما حدث
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا من جديد مراسل
العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد اهلا بك عبد
الجواد مره اخرى وكما تابعنا التصريحات
الرسميه الروسيه جاءت مشككه في هذه
التقارير الغربيه حول
نورد ستريم هل يعني ذلك بشكل او باخر هل
هناك
نيه لروسيا الرسميه ان تجري تحقيقات خاصه
بها بالتوازي مع هذه التحقيقات الغربيه
عفوا
مرحبا احمد من جديد نعم يعني بالفعل موسكو
تحدثت مرات عده عن نيتها اجراء تحقيقات
بما اي او تحقيق يعني بما يخص قضيه تفجير
انابيب نرد ستريم التي اعتمدت عليها موسكو
طويلا في نقل لغازها نحو الاراضي
الالمانيه لكن حتى هذه اللحظه لا يسمح لها
لا باجراء هذه التحقيقات على ارض الواقع
ولا للوصول لوثائق التحقيقات التي اجرتها
دول اوروبيه فيما يخص هذا الموضوع طبعا
احمد لابد من لفت الانتباه الى ان
التصريحات ايضا شملت وزاره الخارجيه بعد
ان بعد ان حملت يعني زخارف يوم امس الغرب
مسؤوليه اما حدث ووصفتهم بانهم يقومون
بتغيير الحقائق للفت انتباه المجتمع برمته
يعني حول نقاط اخرى يمكنها الابتعاد عن
الجهه الرئيسيه التي قامت بتفجير هذه
الانابيب بصراحه احمد يعني الداخل الروسي
ان كان على الصعيد الرسمي او على الصعيد
السياسي او على الصعيد المجتمع والناس
يرون في قضيه موردسريم هو اعتداء صريح على
ممتلكات روسيه وطبعا موسكو تحدثت اكثر من
مره بانها لن تعود وتسبح من جديد
بالاعتداء على خط انابيب يعني الغاز
والطاقه التي توردها لدول عده باعتبار هذا
الموضوع يعتبر من الامن القومي لروسيا
وطبعا موسكو لوحت باستخدام كافه انواع
السلاح في حال تكرار هذا الموضوع لكن قضيه
نور ستريم التحقيقات فيها ما زالت جاريه
هناك بعض المطالبات من الداخل بالعمل على
هذا الموضوع بطارب يعني بطرق اكثر جديه
لكن كل الطرق حتى هذه اللحظه مع الجانب
الغربي ما زالت مغلقه حسب تصريحات الرسميه
شكرا لك على كل هذه المعلومات والتوضيحات
بمواصف كنت معنا مراسل العربيه
تحياتي عبد الجواد
نشاطنا مستمر مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
الاتحاد الاوروبي يطالب ايران بتوضيح سبب
العثور على اثار يورانيوم للتخصيب ويعتبره
تطورا غير مسبوق
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد اكد متحدث في
مجلس محافظه الاتحاد الاوروبي ان الاتحاد
مازال ملتزما بالاتفاق النووي مع ايران
واعرب المتحدث الاوروبي عن قلقه الشديد من
العثور على اثار يورانيوم ومخصب بنسبه
تقارب اربعه
وقال ان هذا الامر تطورا خطير وغير مسبوق
ودع المتحدث ايران التعاون بشكل كامل
وجفاف مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
يشان العثور على اثار يورانيوم عالي
التخصيب في احدى المنشات النوويه هذا وداع
مندوب روسيا لدى المنظمات الدوليه في
فيينا
دعا جميع المشاركين في المحادثات النوويه
الايرانيه للعوده الى العاصمه النمساويه
من اجل احياء الاتفاق النووي وقال
اوليانوب في البيان الروسي بشان الملف
الايراني امام مجلس محافظ الوكاله الدوليه
انه يمكن تبديد مخاوفهم العديده بسهوله
مشترطا عوده المشاركين في المحادثات الى
فيينا من اجل وضع اللمسات الاخيره في غضون
ايام قليله على مسوده قرار بشان استعاده
العمل بالاتفاق النووي
هذا وطلب جيم ريتش كبير الجمهوريين في
لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي طالب الولايات المتحده بالتركيز
على خطه بديله فيما يتعلق بملف نووي
الايراني وقال ريتشا عبر تويتر انما وصفها
بالمغامره النوويه الايرانيه تتطلب توبيخا
صريحا من مجلس محافظ الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه واتهم السيناتور الامريكيه
طهران بانها تتعامل بسوء نيه
وعلى خلفيه حالات تسمم طالبات ايران اعلنت
وزاره الداخليه الايرانيه اعتقال عده
اشخاص في ست محافظات منها خوزستان
واذربيجان الغربيه الداخليه الايرانيه
مشاهدينا قالت ان ثلاثه اشخاص من التابعين
لاحدى الفرق المكونه من اربعه اشخاص لديهم
تاريخ قضائي سيء من القيام باحتجاجات
وارتباط مع وسائل اعلام خارجيه على حد
قولها فيما اثار اعلان الداخليه الايرانيه
موجه استياء واسعه خصوصا بعد تحميل
مواطنين شاركوا في الاحتجاجات الاخيره
المسؤوليه فضلا عن المحها بتورط وسائل
اعلام العدو
واحتجاجا على الثمار مسلسل تسنيم فتيات
المدارس في مختلف المدن الايرانيه تجمع
المعلمون واهالي الطلاب امام المديريه
العامه للتربيه والتعليم بحسب المجلس
التنسيقي الايراني لنقابات المعلمين وبعد
مطالبات المحتجين بوضع حد للقمع البيولوجي
وتهديد حياه المواطنين وخاصه التلميذات تم
اعتقال سته اعضاء من مجلس اداره المعلمين
في واصيب اثنان بالخرطوش نتابع
[موسيقى]
لا يزال الغموض سيده موقفي حوادث التسمم
في ايران ضحايا دون متهم وجريمه كامله
الاركان بلا مجرم الجديد لكنه ليس مستغربا
ان تعود جميع اصابع الاتهام التي اطلقها
النظام نحوه مباشره
فعمليه التصميم المنظمه والمنهجه التي
طالت حوالي 230 مدرسه في 25 محافظه وصممت
اكثر من خمسه الاف تلميذه هي براي مطلعين
من تخطيط داخلي منظم وليس عشوائيا
استهداف الفتيات تحديدا مؤشر ثان على تورط
النظام في الجريمه البشعه والتي وان لم
تسفر عن وفيات يرجح انها تسبب حاله ذعر
مزمنه حاله تلبي حاجه النظام بقطع راس
ثوره امراه حياه حريه التي لا تزال مشتعله
لكن العكس تماما هو ما حصل فاليوم اندلعت
احتجاجات اولياء الطالبات على ما وصف
بالهجمات الكيماويه في كل من طهران
والشيراز والاهواز ورشت وبابل وبشهر
وهمدان وزنجان واردبيل وسننذج وكرمانشاه
وكراج ومشهد
بعد ثلاثه اشهر من تسجيل اولى حالات
التسمم والتي اشتدت هذا الاسبوع تعلن
السلطات الايرانيه اليوم عن توقيف خمسه
مشتبهين دون الكشف عن هويتهم او حتى
الاعتراف بالتقصير بواجبها في حمايه
المواطنين
خوذه
خارجياس
خيل بيور زيد
يا ايها الجالسون التسمم التالي لابنائكم
والموت للنظام القاتل للاطفال شعارات اخرى
علقت وخطه على جدران المؤسسات الحكوميه
كلمات لقد صدن خارج ايران وصدمه كبيره في
المانيا ودعوه من الامم المتحده وامريكا
لاجراء تحقيق مستقل يكشف سر السم الصامت
في انحاء ايران
وفي حديثي للعربيه شددت المتحدثه باسم
البيت الابيض كارين جينفير على انه يجب
الا تمر انتهاكات حقوق الانسان التي
ترتكبها طهران ضد المتظاهرين الا تمر دون
محاسبه
اضافت ان الولايات المتحده ترحب بدعوه
مجلس الشيوخ لبعثه الامم المتحده الدوليه
المستقله لتقصي الحقائق بشان ايران
[موسيقى]
تبدو غامضه
وتقدم استفهامات اكثر ما تقدم اجابات
واضحه
هل هو غموض مفتعل ام ان النظام هو ايضا
ضحيه لهذه الحوادث
تحياتي لك الكرام
الغموض قد يكون غموض متعمد حسب كثير من
اطراف المعارضه ينظرون الى الامر هكذا
السلطات تقول بانها تبذل جهودها لكشف
ملابسات
وحيثيات هذه الهجمات وتتهم بعض الاحيان
الاعداء
وبعض الاحيان تتهم
اطراف قد تكون داخليه ولكن غير
غير مقصوده بما قامت به هذا ما قاله يوم
امس
مساعد وزير وزير الداخليه الايراني
المعارضون يقولون بان النظام يحاول وفقا
احدى الفرضيات يحاول النظام خلق حاله من
الذعر والخوف
والهدف من وراء ذلك هدفين الهدف الاول
اخافه المحتجين والهدف الاخر ان تخويف
المجتمع الايراني من لو سقط النظام سيعم
اللامن في البلد بسبب فقدان السيطره على
البلاد هذا ما يحاول تقول بعض اطراف
المعارضه وهي تتمسك بهذه الفرضيه ولكن
النظام هو الذي في واقع الامن يمهد لمثل
هذه النظريات وهذه الاتهامات اليوم مولوي
عبد الحميد الزعيم الروحي
للبلوش واحد كبار زعماء السنه في ايران
قال ربما هناك ايادي داخل النظام تقف وراء
[موسيقى]
تسمم
للطالبات في المدارس الايرانيه طيب لكن
اعتقال مشتبه بهم اليوم كما اعلن النظام
الايراني الا يبرئ صحه النظام هذا
الاتهامات التي اشرت اليها
حتى المشتبه بهم لا توجد اي معلومات من هم
هؤلاء ما هي الاتهامات الموجهه لهم مثلا
ثلاثه من الاشخاص التهمه لهم هي بث مواد
تحريضيه
هل هؤلاء قاموا ببث امور تحريضيه تتعلق
بالتسمم ام انهم كانوا ضالعين في عمليات
التسمم لا تزال الامور غامضه وهذا الغموض
باعتقادي ليس لصالح النظام الايراني لانه
في النهايه قد يكون هناك طرف في النظام
يحاول ان
يبث الخوف والرعب بين الناس ولكن قد يتحول
هذا الى شيء ذو حدين وتندلع الاحتجاجات
بشكل اوسع مما كانت عليه في السابق شكرا
لك من دبي كنت معنا الباحث في ايراني
مسعود الفكتحيد مسعود شكرا
مشاهدينا اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي رصد
عمليه اطلاق صاروخ من قطاع غزه صوب
مستوطنات الغلاف ما ادى الى تفعيل صافره
الانذار في المستوطنات المحيطه بها ومن
جهتها قالت مصادر محليه في قطاع غزه ان
الفصائل الفلسطينيه اطلقت الصاروخين من
نوع 107 اتجاه موقع عسكري اسرائيلي في
مستوطنات غلاف غزه وذلك بعد ان رفع الجيش
الاسرائيلي حاله التاهب الى القصوى بعد
عمليه عسكريه ادت الى مقتل سته فلسطينيين
بينهم ينفذ عمليه حواره التي اسفرت عن
مقتل مستوطنين وهذه الصوره المباشره
مشاهدينا من غزه بعد اطلاق صاروخ من
القطاع باتجاه مستوطنات اسرائيليه هذه
الصور مباشره مشاهدينا كما ذكرنا من قطاع
غزه بعد الحديث عن اطلاق صاروخ من قطاع
باتجاه بسطره اسرائيليه اطلقت فيها ايضا
صافرات الانذار كل ذلك مشاهدينا ياتي في
وسط التوتر الذي نجم بعد اقتحام القوات
الاسرائيليه لقريه حوار يوم امس وقتلها
سته فلسطينيين بينهم
ينفذ العمليه التي نفذت داخل المناطق
الاسرائيليه واسفرت عن مقتل مستوطنهم نذكر
مشاهدينا بان الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن رصد
عمليه اطلاق صاروخ من قطاع غزه صورته الان
بشكل مباشر صوب مستوطنات الغلاف ما ادى
الى تفعيل صافرات الانذار في المستوطنات
المحيطه بها مصادر ايضا محليه مشاهدينا في
قطاع غزه اكدت ان الفصائل الفلسطينيه
اطلقت صاروخين من نوع 107 اتجاه موقع
عسكري اسرائيلي في مستوطنه غلا في غزه وكل
ذلك المشاهدين ياتي بعد ان رفع الجيش
الاسرائيلي حاله التاهب الى القصوى بعد
عمليه عسكريه ادت الى مقتل سته فلسطينيين
بينهم منفذ عمليه حواره التي اسفرت عن
مقتل مستوطنين
ادان المنسق الخاسئ من المتحده لعمليه
السلام في الشرق الاوسط هجمات المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين على الفلسطينيين في بلده
حوار بضفه الغربيه ودعا الى وقف العنف
فورا وابدا خلقه من هجوم الجيش الاسرائيلي
على جنين في ضفه الغربيه ما اسفر كما
ذكرنا عن مقتل سته
في بيان لوقف دائره العنف والكف عن المزيد
من الخطوات التي تقود الى التصعيد نتابع
الثانيه ظهرا تتوغل قوات خاصه اسرائيليه
في شاحنه تجاريه وقوات كبيره من الجيش
الاسرائيلي والطيران الحربي يحلق فرقها
مخيم جنين يحاصرون هذا المنزل وتبدا
المعركه مع من تحصنوا بداخله يطلق نار كل
نواحي كان الاتفاق نار نوعين نوع يعني
عليه كاتمه وهو للقوات الخاصه ونوع عادي
ثمره المعركه طبعا ضرب على بيتنا قضيه ان
يرجع الاول ثم بدا
الصواريخ على الكتف على هذا المنزل علمنا
من وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي للمستهدف منزل
جارنا فجلسنا هنا اطلقت 16 قذيفه كتف
هذا الدمار قد يدلل على ان الوضع الميداني
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه معزول تماما عن
الوضع السياسي وسط ضغوط امريكيه واوروبيه
لتهدئه الاوضاع على الارض ترافقها تصريحات
رسميه اسرائيليه بالتزامها بالتهدئه من
مخيم جنين خالد القاسم العربيه
نشرتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
بعد شهرين من انتقال كريستيانو رونالدو
الى صفوف نادي النصر السعودي مقطع فيديو
يظهر ابنتيهما الانا وايفا وهما تتحدثان
وتغنيان بالعربيه
زعيم قوه فاجنر يعلن السيطره على البوابه
الشرقيه لباخ متوازير من تداعيات سقوطها
الانفجار كان بالتزامن مع التحليق طائره
مسيره عند ضفاف البراد والتجاره المرصد
يقول انفجار استهدف مبنى للمليشيات
الايرانيه في دير الزور وخلف قتلى وجرحه
ما في مشكله بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
مشكله بين الناس المكرسين بالسلطه
في هجوم اللعب عقائد قوات الدعم السريع
السودانيه ينتقد العسكريين المتمسكين
بالسلطه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد التقى ولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان برئيس
مجلس القياده الرئيسيه اليمني رشاد
العليمي حيث اكد على دعم المملكه لجهود
التوصل الى حل سياسي في اليمن وجرى خيار
الاجتماع استعراض مستجدات الاوضاع على
الساحه اليمنيه والتاكيد ايضا على استمرار
دعم السعوديه للمجلسي والحكومه اليمنيه
والشعب اليمني ودعم كل الجهود للتوصل لحل
سياسي شامل في اليمن برعايه امم المتحده
لتحقيق الامن والاستقرار
في هجوم على العسكريين المتمسكين بالسلطه
انتقد قائد قوات الدعم السريعه السودانيه
اللواء محمد حمدانو العسكريين الذين
يسيطرون على مقاليد الحكم في البلاد مؤكدا
انهم يعرضون التنحي للسماحي بانتقال
ديمقراطي في ظل اداره مدنيه وشدد على ان
صراعه مع القاده العسكريين الاخرين الذين
اصبح الذي اصبح علنيا في الاسابيع الاخيره
يتمحور حول مساله تسليم السلطه المدنيين
واضاف متحدثا لقوات الدعم السريع انه لا
يوجد خلاف بين الجيش والدعم السريع ولكن
الخلافه يكمن مع الذين يقفون ضد تسليم
السلطه الى حكومه مدنيه نتابع
وارادتنا ان احنا كنا نسلم الحكومه لحكومه
مدنيه كامله الدسم
التحول الديمقراطي حقيقي
من اكتر من ستين سنه ده وهنا الدعم السريع
اصلا الدعم القوات المسلحه
والدعم الشديد اخواني جاي ببرلمان ما جاي
حكم قرقوش حكومه مدنيه تحول ديمقراطي
حكومه مدنيه المشكله في زول يا جماعه ما
درى الكلام
في فرنسا تظاهر اكثر من مليون و 200 الف
شخص احتجاجا على مشروع قانون اصلاح نظام
التقاعد ويعد هذا التحرك امتداد لتحركات
سابقه اخرى حدثت خلال الشهري الماضيين
الحراك ياتي تحت شعار اغلاق فرنسا حيث
يشمل قطاعات استراتيجيه فضلا عن انه يمهد
الطريق امام بدايه اضراب مفتوح يمتد لايام
اسبوع حاسم تعيشه فرنسا في ظل معركه قانون
التقاعد ثماني نقابات عماليه دعت الى
تظاهرات مليونيه تحت عنوان اغلاق فرنسا
ياتي ذلك بالتزامن مع دراسه مجلس الشيوخ
لمشروع القانون لمواجهه ذلك حشدت السلطات
الاف عناصر الشرطه انتشروا في شوارع
العاصمه بشكل خاص ولكن ايضا في معظم المدن
الفرنسيه حيث سجل خروج 260 تظاهره لكن ذلك
لم يمنع من وقوع اشتباكات بين المتظاهرين
والشرطه استخدمت الاخيره خلالها الغاز
المسيل للدموع ووقعت بعض الاصابات في صفوف
المتظاهرين ويشمل الاضراب قطاعات كثيره من
بينها الصحه والتعليم والمواصلات والطاقه
حيث سجل مشاركه نحو 40% من المدرسين بهذا
الاضراب في حين الغت هيئه الطيران المدني
ما بين 20 الى 30% من رحلات الطيران واثر
ذلك على رحلات الطيران والقطارات بين
فرنسا وبريطانيا بشكل خاص النقابات تسعى
لان يتواصل الاضراب لايام عديده وذلك بهدف
ايقاف فرنسا وشل اقتصادها من اجل الحكومه
على التراجع
فدهوك العربيه باريس ونبقى في فرنسا حيث
قالت قائده الشرطه الحدود الفرنسيه مع
ايطاليا الى العربي ان بلادها بدات تتشدد
في فرض الرقابه على عبور المهاجرين غير
القانونين للنقاط الحدوديه بين البلدين
لعده اسباب من بينها الخشيه من ان يقوم
احدها هؤلاء بعمل يؤذي فرنسا كما حصل اكثر
من مره في مدينه نيس المزيد مع الزميل
حسين قنبر نحن هنا في بلده في اقصى جنوب
فرنسا هنا محطه قطارات هي الاولى التي
يعبر منها الواصلون من ايطاليا نحو
الاراضي الفرنسيه سنرافق بعد دقائق من
الان وحده خاصه من الشرطه الفرنسيه ستصعد
على متن قطار لتدقق في هويات الركاب كل
الذين لا يحملون هويات دقيقه وصحيحه سيعاد
تسليمهم الى السلطات الايطاليه
يصل القطار نصعد اليه مع عناصر شرطه
الحدود ويشمل التدقيق في الهويات عددا
كبيرا من الركاب القادمين من فانتيميليا
الايطاليه تنجح الشرطه في توقيف مهاجر غير
شرعي من غينيا يجري اقتياده بعد ذلك الى
نقطه الحدود البريه تمهيدا لاعادته الى
ايطاليا تنظم يوميا عده عمليات من هذا
النوع والحصيله توقيف عشرات الداخلين الى
فرنسا دون اوراق شرعيه كل يوم في هذه
المنطقه التي يقصدها السياح ساحلا وجبلا
يحاول المهاجرون الالتفاف على الاجراءات
الامنيه وقلم ينجحون امانيوال قائدة
الشرطه الحدوديه في هذه المنطقه قالت
للعربيه ان من بين اهداف التشدد في
المراقبه حمايه امن الفرنسيين فرنسا تضبط
حدودها كي تتاكد من انه لا يوجد بين
المهاجرين اشخاص سياتون الينا لارتكاب
اعمال مؤذيه لانه سبق وحصلت اعتداءات
فينيس ارتكب احدها شخص كان من ضمن الذين
دخلوا بطريقه غير شرعيه انتقلنا الى
الايطاليه حيث يعيش مصطفى الصومالي مع
اليكس النيجيريا حياه تشبه حياه العصر
الحجري من اول نجيب من ليبيا انا من
الصومال الجنسيه هنا بالوادي النايمين ولا
شيء واشتغل ولا شيء انا بدي عيالي وعائلتي
يجي من هنا
13 سنه ما شف تقول ايطاليا انها استقبلت
العام الماضي وحده اكثر من مئه الف مهاجر
غير شرعي فيما استقبلت فرنسا بضعه الاف
فقط حسين قنيبر العربيه من منطقه الحدود
الايطاليه الفرنسيه
اذا مشاهدينا بعد شركه هواوي والمناطيد
طريقه اخرى محتمله للتجسس الصيني في
الولايات المتحده هذه المره عبر رافعات
عملاقه في موانئ امريكيه فالمسؤلون قلقون
من استخدامها كادوات للتيسس محتمل
لاحتوائها استشعار يمكن التحكم بها عن بعد
لجمع معلومات استخباراتيه وتصنع شركه بي
ام سي الصينيه نحو 80% من رافعات الشحن
المستخدمه في الموانئ الامريكيه حسب صحيفه
عملاقه عاديه كما تبدو وموجوده
في امريكا لكن
القلق او المسؤولين حولها كونها صينيه
الصنع ويمكن ان تستخدمها كادوات تجسس
محتمله حسب تقرير
مسؤولون في الامن القومي والبنتاجون
يقولون ان الرافعات التي تصنعها شركه
الصينيه تضم اجهزه استشعار متطوره تستطيع
تسجيل وتتبع مصدر ووجهات الحاويات حتى في
موانئ يستخدمها الجيش الامريكي وبالتالي
يمكن لهذه الرافعات جمع معلومات استخباريه
عن المعدات العسكريه التي تشحن لدعم
العمليات العسكريه الامريكيه في الخارج ما
يعيده الى الاذهان موضوعه معدات شركه
الاتصالات الصينيه هواوي
التحدي الرئيسي الذي تواجهه الولايات
المتحده وهيمنه الصين على الكثير من
التكنولوجيا المستخدمه في التصنيع لذلك في
اي وقت تستخدم فيه الولايات المتحده
اتصالات صينيه شركه تصنيع رافعات صينيه او
اي معدات صينيه متطوره جدا تجعلها عرضه
لوصول السن الى البيانات
عام 2021 عثر عملاء الاف بي اي على متن
سفينه شحن تنقل رافعه
على معدات لجمع معلومات استخباراتيه لكن
مسؤولي الامن القوميه لم يذكروا ما اذا
كانوا قد وجدوا اي حالات محدده لاستخدام
رافعات الشركه في التجسس وتشغل الرافعات
عبر برامج حاسوب صينيه يقول مسؤولون
امريكيون انهم يتلقون احيانا الدعم من
مواطنين صينيين ما قد يكون احد سبل جمع
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
الشركات هذه الصينيه لن تسمح لاحد انه
يقترب من اجهزتها او يبرمجها بطريقتهم
لانها هي مخصصه ومصنوعه في الصين ومبرمجه
في الصين هذا سبب انهم جايبين المبرمجين
الصينيين هذا السبب فيها بالنسبه للنقطه
الثانيه اي جهاز يوصلك للانترنت تقدر انت
ترسل المعلومات اللي تحتاجها لو مثلا في
كاميرات في الرافعات هذه لو في اي اجهزه
تحسس في الرافعات ممكن توصل المعلومات الى
الى الصين
ووفق تقارير امنيه تستطيع الصين عبر
التحكم عن بعد الرافعات خنقه حركه المرور
في الموانئ وفي السنوات الاخيره اشار
مسؤول الامن القومي الى مجموعه من المعدات
المصنعه في الصين منها انظمه فحص الامتعه
والمحولات الكهربائيه التي يمكن ان تسهل
المراقبه او الاضطرابات في الولايات
المتحده حسب جورنال حسين الطاوض العربيه
من ميناء بالتيمور في ولايه ميريلاند
بعد شهرين من انتقال اللاعب البرتغالي
كريستيانو رونالدو الى صفوف نادي النصر
السعودي والاستقرار رفقه عائلته في
السعوديه نشرت جورجينا رودريكلز عارضه
الازياء عبر حسابها في الانستجرام نشرت
مقطع فيديو يظهر ابنتيها الانا وايفا وهما
تتحدثان وتغنيان بالعربيه
مع اسرتي
احبتي
احب لامي
احبائي
الجمعه السبت الثلاثاء الاربعاء الخميس
الجمعه
[موسيقى]
زعيم قوهها
الانفجار كان بالتزامن مع التحليق طائره
مسيره الايرانيه
حالات التسمم بين الفتيات في تزايد وايران
تعلن ايقاف عدد من المشتبه بهم وتصفهم
بالمشاغبين
ما في مشكله بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
مشكله بين الناس المكرسين بالسلطه
في هجوم لا بعقائد قوات الدعم السريع
السودانيه ينتقد العسكريين المتمسكين
بالسلطه
نهايه هذه النشر مشاهدينا شكرا حسن
المتابعه وفي امان الله
[موسيقى]